I think I'll be able to answer quite well if I'm asked what I like about Ana-
sama because I just have a good house already
Tsukasa-chan, let's keep important luggage in the room
.
Episode 8 is over, but if it's this one, I think it'll be fine if you change
it up.  Hey,
my landlord said it was caused by a lightning strike
.  I have it in a safety deposit box, and I have home insurance for the furniture, so it's
not that easy to get
insurance.
Since the materials are in the cloud and in the safety deposit box, there will be no problems.
I'll try to think about it while soaking in the bathtub.
I
love you so much I
thought you were a really nice person